fatiha bibi comment vivez-vous ce débat
sur le voile depuis plusieurs jours
plusieurs semaines ça commence à devenir
fatigant parce qu'il ya d'autres
problèmes plus importants que ceux là le
fait qu'une femme porte le voile c'est
quoi un pape en armes sinon on
n'apprenait pas des touristes
il faut arrêter ces faux débat voilà
c'est tout c'est les médias et à
certains médias
certains policiers les sommes soi-disant
de culture qu'ils ont qu'ils ont
commencé à bien tous ses problèmes en
fait ils ont créé ce problème c'est du
racisme pur et simple entre l'islam est
contre
quand on est femme voilée c'est les
médias et les politiques pour vous qui
sont responsables de ce débat route a
fait tout à fait vrai tu as fait ils
veulent justement diviser pour mieux
régner
divisez de francs de français entre eux
au mur pour mieux régner
qu'est ce que vous ressentez vous
concrètement personnellement quand vous
entendez ces débats là et ces questions
justement moi je me sens une sous
française sincèrement je me sens plus
française comme je l'étais auparavant
parce que je suis un peu gênante dans un
pays de liberté de fraternité d'égalité
ses valeurs c'est bien ça et j'étais
donc on part dans le décor républicaine
et je me sens voilà je me sens on
dénigre et de par ma religion est
vraiment folle à interdire le voile lors
des sorties scolaires pour les
accompagnants quelles conséquences
aurait pour vous ça voudrait dire que
vous pourriez plus accompagner vos
enfants déjà déjà ces mamans qui portent
le voile qui accompagnent ces enfants
déjà le font volontiers déjà et la
majorité parce que justement il ya
beaucoup de moments ne sont pas
disponibles par le travail passoire et
c'est maman si elle amène pas les
enfants en sortie pour me pénaliser ceux
qui ce sont les enfants
voilà et en plus le foulard n'est pas
dans le privé en droit public puisque
sur l'extérieur donc je vois pas c'est
un faux débat
pourquoi parler de deux femmes qu'il
faut l'approfondir dit tristement mal à
amener les enfants
le premier qui m'a pénalisé avec les
enfants et savage et d'encourager
d'autres problèmes avec des enfants qui
sortent actuellement nos enfants nos
petits-enfants sont en panne de demain
votre datacenter extension
l'interdiction du voile musulman ce sont
rabaissées sont insultés je sais pas moi
est-ce que vous avez l'impression le
sentiment en tout cas que les regards
ont changé depuis quelques temps tout à
fait oui enfin moi j'ai pas ce problème
là pas trouvés marseille puis quand même
solidarité côte monde pour l'histoire
que je n'arrive pas même eu des
problèmes mais c'est vrai quand je lis
les journaux et que je je je vois
souvent depuis quelques temps la
dilatation ceux des femmes voilées
c'est lamentable
vous vous sentez personnellement du coup
concernés touché quand ça arrive le
blessure ça me concerne mais ça me
concerne parce que ça concerne ma foi ça
concernant ma religion et ça me touche
bien sûr qu'elle me touche parce que
j'appelle ça peut m'arriver nommé comme
en général je sais pas mais ça me
concerne ça me concerne j'ai passé tous
ces problèmes là ça crée des tensions
d'ailleurs on le voit avec le la
question de qui à vue à bayonne
cette fois c'est le stade de quoi sa
table tout ce qui se passe en ce moment
par rapport à la religion
voilà des gens qu'ils ont des préjugés
de qui
les stigmates certains musulmans en
disant qu'on ne connaît de déroute menée
par jean faller d'interroger parle
français comme vous je m'exprime pas en
vous je ne sais pas quand vous donc
voila apres voilà il faut pas non plus
viser certains français par rapport à
d'autres je vous remercie d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur public sénat
merci